[Music]  you can see the world you brought to  life  to live  [Music]  life  I'll pick you up a five I may not be  done by then you insist under fire my  mrs. gray what should I do about that  I know there wasn't it I bought it for  us Christian this is the architect I'm  going to build you a fabulous house  please stop speaking of my husband as if  I weren't here in you may call me mrs.  gray  [Music]  look out your window why you know I'm  taking you away for the weekend  you own this we own this nose mom I just  can't believe this was my life that I  get to live with you it meant nothing to  me  before you how the hell are you Anna  Jack what do you want Korea follows  see what pleasure yes sir right  I made a vow to love you faithfully  forsaking all others  they come 41 times of need and to keep  you safe first long as we both shall  live  it seems you're pregnant mrs. gray we  did our  [Applause]  [Music]  you